des éleveurs qui trépignent d'impatience
jusqu'à ce qu'elle a dès les portes pour
découvrir leur nouvelle acquisition
alors en attendant l'ouverture des boks
on se taquine entre professionnels du
métier qu'ils soient à la maison commun
comme pau à flers vaches laitières
malraux producteurs un arrivage de 10
des vols des limousines des blondes
d'aquitaine
mais la star de la journée c'est lui le
partenaire importé pour la première fois
en martinique est sélectionné pour ses
caractéristiques parents never de la
codem la coopérative des éleveurs bovins
une bête en fait très arrondi très bien
ce qu'ils nous font martinique
nous faisons du croisement industriel
avec la vache brahmanes est une bête
qu'est ce que l'éthique avec pas
vraiment très agréable il faut lui
mettre de la vienne dessus autre raison
les sabots douars et les poils ras nous
avons trop graphie ici un seul vraiment
difficile très caillouteux vous savez en
france métropolitaine
ça n'existe presque pas en fait en la
solidité au niveau de saint benoît et le
programme aussi contre les tiques sont
des animaux qui sont dans un pays
tempéré donc les adapter sur la partie
tropicale c'est pas évident donc trouver
le juste milieu
premièrement qualité en conformation et
surtout cela durée et la durée de leur
vie sur la martinique
un investissement pour serveur chaque
bête vaut entre 8000 et 9000 euros
finalement je suis devenu un petit peu
le vert or en complément de ma canne à
sucre j'ai franchi le pas pour voir et
j'ai bon espoir bien sûr ma manche
la codem organise ses importations de
bovins chaque année pour s'assurer du
maintien du niveau de production locale